hello everyone
welcome to what i think many of you know
is a truly historic day
for science for astronomy for really
human ingenuity and the
the passion to explore you know our
our programming here at the world
science festival is under the banner of
big ideas the big idea series what we're
talking about today is among
the really biggest ideas because it
spans not only
trying to understand the cosmos but to
explore the cosmos to observe the cosmos
to measure the cosmos in ways
that we have never done before of course
i'm talking about the james webb space
telescope
you may recall that it launched
back on christmas day 2021
traveled
around a million miles out into space
to the l2 point the second lagrange
point for those of you who remember your
classical mechanics
then spent a nice period of time
unfurling the sun shade that will
protect the delicate imagery unfolding
the 21-foot mirror with these 18
hexagonal pieces fitted together like a
jigsaw puzzle
and then began
observing the cosmos and today
the first images from the james webb
space telescope were
released
and we're going to have a discussion
with some of the key people responsible
for this amazing technological
scientific feat we're gonna have a
conversation about those images what
they tell us
both about the capacity of the telescope
as well as the insights that perhaps we
are going to gain in the next weeks
months years as it turns out even
decades so joining me first
for this conversation
is someone who is familiar to
many of you he's been on many of our
world science festival programs in the
past i'm referring of course to nobel
prize winner and senior project
scientist for the james webb space
telescope
john
mather so john
welcome to
the conversation
my goodness thank you for having us
yeah and i can't imagine what it must
feel like
i mean you've been at this for what 25
years maybe actually more um it feels
like a tremendous relief because
something that was really pretty scary
worked out very well in the end
and um very exciting to see the
possibilities coming because we never
knew what this telescope would actually
show us until we did it so we just
finished setting it up on sunday
so can you just take us through that
we're going to bring in a number of your
colleagues in just a moment to go
through some of the
the images that
were released today but can you just
set the scene for us i briefly went
through
the history but you know so from launch
until today what's been happening
well it took us as you said two weeks to
unfold the telescope then it took us
another
um almost four months to finish setting
up the telescope itself and then another
two months to
uh finish setting up the instruments so
we know how to focus them all how to set
up the exposure times all the things you
have to do
with a very complicated digital camera
so there it is out in space and it's got
all these filters to choose and the
exposure calculator and all those things
we have to verify that it's really in
focus so we did that and now we are sure
it's working and
and were there moments when
you metaphorically or literally were
holding your breath because if such and
such didn't happen it was over is that
the kind of situation that you faced
well of course it is but uh i'm not good
at holding my breath so
um i'm take a take it as as it comes you
know we built it we did everything we
could to make it work
and as it turned out everything worked
we didn't have to go to the backup plan
for anything so it's a testament to the
brilliant engineering that we did and
the brilliant people that made that
possible
what about that that we heard certainly
i i didn't follow it in detail because
it turned out i'd gather to not be a big
deal but
a little space
pellet rock something hidden yeah
it did indeed we've actually had about
six of them uh only one was really
noticeable but even that one was about a
thousandth of an inch across if you had
it in your fingers you'd never know
but it travels at maybe 30 000
kilometers sorry 30 kilometers a second
you know that's fast enough to hurt
so
it did actually make a little dent
and it's okay
but it's okay all right well great and
and and so before i bring in four of
your colleagues to discuss some of the
images in detail and i'm of course i'd
love to hear your
detailed comments on those images as
well but overall
i i mean are you over the moon with
maybe that's not the right metaphor you
know i should say you know the whole
telescope or over the l2 point whatever
the right metaphor is i mean the whole
galaxy
yeah
we have done what we said we would do it
was incredibly difficult it took forever
it involved all our international
partners in huge aerospace companies
so a teamwork of twenty thousand people
to put this thing together and make it
twenty thousand twenty thousand people
so our project manager bill oaks at
goddard space flight center made that
happen
so um we were thrilled that he did that
and you're going to meet the people that
made this happen building up the
instruments that are in the telescope or
attached to the telescope
i think it's maybe worthwhile saying we
all had history before we got to this
as was mentioned i worked on the kobe
satellite
at the same time we were building that
my friendly competitors who were
stealing the best engineers to work on
the hubble space telescope
and people were already planning the
spitzer space telescope
so at least two of us worked on the
spitzer as well so wow when it came time
to think about what are we going to do
next after the hubble there was already
a conference before hubble's launched
that said this is what we think we need
to do after we got the hubble fixed a
committee wrote a book that said please
build us this and we did what they said
yeah it's amazing it's amazing it's a
brilliant book it gives you goosebumps
to read it
yeah uh i'll have to check it out but
that really is just a an amazing even
summary story of uh
an incredible achievement so let me
bring in
some of the folks that you just
made reference to uh pierre farway
george and marsha rieke they've spent i
gather almost as much time
devoted to the web telescope as you have
maybe not quite as many years but uh
certainly have devoted significant part
of their professional lives over the
past couple of decades
leading the development of a number of
the key
scientific instruments that make the web
telescope what it is so more
specifically marcia is the principal
investigator for the near infrared
camera known as near cam which produced
the stunning
deep space image that many of us saw
president biden react to unveil
yesterday which was a which certainly
was a fun moment pierre is the european
space agency's project scientist for the
near infrared spectrograph known as near
spec which is using innovative
technology to help scientists find the
earliest galaxies in the universe
and george is the science team lead for
the mid-infrared instrument known as
miri which measures infrared wavelengths
that are beyond the scope of either near
camera near spec has no doubt we will
hear as we go forward so i'd like to
welcome them to our discussion we also
may have uh rene oh oh we do have
everybody fantastic i wasn't sure if
renee bayonne was here but he's the
principal investigator for canada's
contribution to the web telescope which
can be thought of in some sense as a
twofer it's a fine guidance system and
also a near infrared imager and slit
this spectrograph known as near s
so let's jump right in first of all
thank you all for taking time out for
what must be an incredibly busy day to
have a exploration and conversation
about the images that were released i'd
like to begin
with the first the the deep
space image that
president biden saw yesterday and it was
it was quite
it's quite touching yesterday to see
president biden almost like a little kid
you know just so excited by
all of the ideas that are embodied in
this image so
marcia let's begin with you because i
think near cam your
instrument plays certainly a key role in
in fashioning this image can tell us
what we're seeing here and and how you
go about extracting the data that allows
an image like this to uh to be shown to
the world
okay what you're seeing is a near cam
image that's comprised of six different
colors
near cam can measure two colors at once
so it took three different exposure
settings to get these six colors
and you can see if you look closely
there are some objects that are
very red and then some that are look
much bluer
you will also see some objects um
just a little bit right of center that
that look kind of like little arcs
what we're seeing is a
galaxy cluster that's about
4 billion light years away in other
words we're seeing some whitish fuzzy
elliptical shaped galaxies at the center
that are the star cluster
in the
that is far enough away that the earth
was hardly formed
and it has the effect of its
gravitational field bending light so we
get these funny arc-like things that are
actually background galaxies
elsewhere in the image you can see
little smudges that are very distant
galaxies and
when you have these six colors from near
cam
what you can do
is
make some what i would call guesstimates
of how far away they are by the
distribution of the colors
and one of the ways that pierre and i
have teamed our teams have come together
to use web
for a project that will be done in
september
is to take an image like this
figure out from the colors which are
likely to be the most interesting
distant galaxies
and then use
near-spec to take spectra of them
which is exactly what was done with this
instrument this image as well
so we're seeing as far as i can estimate
not all the way back to the big bang but
within a few hundred million years and
we're hoping in timber that we'll get
within maybe 50 million years
and so einstein would certainly be
thrilled by those arcs no doubt
something that comes right out i mean
you know any of us who teach the general
theory of relativity we teach this to
our students and you know to see it
right there in the imagery is is really
quite stunning but you made reference to
pierre's work and near spec
so so pierre can you tell us
i mean i i think our audience probably
already knows but quickly what is a
you know what does it mean to do
spectroscopy
what does that word mean in this context
and then what do you do with sort of an
image of that sort to take the analysis
even further and perhaps image
on our team image 17 might be a good one
to bring up when pierre is describing it
i think trying to explain
first uh
in fact it's a nearby this one a nearest
image and accompanied by a nearest
spectra
so
to explain basically when you take an
image marcia told about these different
filters so you you look at different
colors spectroscopy you push it further
you break down in colors but
in very large very large number of
small color amounts basically from a few
hundreds to thousands
and you create a spectrum and it's very
similar to what happens
okay when the raindrops
split the light of our sun into a
rainbow as a clear rainbow is a spectrum
of our sun
okay so both near east near spec they
are more sophisticated than raindrops
much more
more accurate also
so we use what we call
grisom or prisms or gratings to to split
the light in its colors and you get this
spectra so then the game is really to
look at
is there what which amount of light do
you get in any color we call them
wavelengths so on these uh diagrams this
is
the x-axis wavelength
and what you see here is that at some
wavelengths at some colors you get
actually a spike of light more light
and it's actually the fingerprint of
some elements in this case the oxygen
and hydrogen
and we know where these these lines are
expected these lines they are expected
and
depending on where we observe them we
can actually figure out
or all this galaxy moves to uh
away from us in this case and in fact
from that get their distances and this
example is striking because you were
talking about einsteins and the
gravitational uh lensing
here you have a two
inverse small squares you can see
two distorted galaxies some arcs which
are actually two images of the same
galaxy we think it's the same uh
galaxies and when you look at the
spectra from nearest you look at them
and you find that indeed this line they
fall exactly at the same place as the
same wavelength
really giving us a stronger
proof but this is the same galaxy okay
they don't have to be of the same amount
of light
because when they get length they get
magnified differently so they may one
may be brighter than the other but
really the telltale sign is the position
of these lines and spectroscopy as you
can see
brings additional information about what
is inside this galaxy so that's kind of
usually terrible yeah okay that's
wonderful so so renee so nearest is a
instrument that is close to
your heart can you take us even a little
bit further into what what we're seeing
and what how does the way in which your
instrument takes the spectrum how does
that differ from say near spec so
there's two of these spectrum
instruments how do they differ
okay so the the image you just shown
that that was a an image from uh
in fact some spectroscopy data from
nearest so this is one of the four
observing modes from nearest so in this
mode we can take spectra
everything everywhere in in the scene
now near spec does it by taking little
slitlets by selecting the object that's
the near spec data here and in fact to
do spectroscopy
that's the way to do it you really want
to isolate your objects from any
background contaminations from other
sources even the sky the sky background
is bright and you want to avoid these
contaminations now
so near spec can take you know a few
hundred objects at the same time now in
nerius we don't have any slits so we
take spectra of everything in the scene
now you do it with less sensitivity
but instead of looking at you know a few
hundred objects you're looking at maybe
you know thousands of objects at the
same time so it's very complementary to
to uh uh to to an airspace to do
spectroscopy and
pierre um and so it's a way to actually
find candidate pirate ship object very
distant objects and then tell new spec
and maybe look that's an object of
interest so you should put your slit on
it to get much more detail so you have a
very good example here uh this one that
has you know show oxygen but which
better the definitions it's an object
that has a
look back time of 13.1 billion years so
that's one of the uh uh observing mode
and what i like of this of this image of
the deep field is that it's it was
observed on all four sciences
instruments it just shows how the four
science and sentiment are complementary
with one another to do one common
science team in this case study the most
distant galaxies in the universe
so let's bring in the fourth instrument
if we could so george you're
dealing with
wavelengths that are a little bit
different than the others can you tell
us well in fact why don't you even tell
us why infrared we haven't actually said
that so that might be a good thing and
why the particular range of wavelengths
that miri focuses upon
so
i'm representing the mid-infrared
instrument that starts at five microns
that's about 10 times longer wavelength
than visible light
and goes out to about 25 microns
and that is a very difficult wavelength
range to observe from the ground because
that's where the infrared emission of
the atmosphere and your telescope just
off the detector
and in fact we learned how to detect
sources that were maybe 100 000 of the
total flux coming onto the detector that
in itself was miraculous
that gave us hints of what to look at
that's where you look for planets for
example planets are right at the
temperature
that glows bright to the mid
mid-infrared instrument
it's where you look for forming stars
because the material that's falling into
the forming stars warms up to exactly
that kind of temperature
so it kind of opens up your sight to a
whole new set of phenomena it's not
dominated by stars and the stellar
emission is dominated by other things
and
that's what's so exciting looking with
webb that
it's above the atmosphere so it's cooled
down so all of this emission goes away
and it's big
big is incredibly important because the
sharpness of your image
depends on how big your telescope is and
so the the resolution element of web
is 150th the resolution element of the
best previous cold telescope we had in
space think of it it's like going from
20 megapixels
going well it's like going from half a
megapixel up to 20 megapixels with your
camera to give you an analogy
yeah and so we're just seeing things we
never saw before this wavelength region
and that's what's going to be so so so
excited i guess i could add at the
beginning mary was kind of an optional
extra on jwc it wasn't one of the
regular instruments i heard you had to
argue for it oh we had to argue for five
or six years
that's quite an argument
it was a long-standing argument but
ten european countries stepped forward
and made contributions
uh nasa eventually decided to buy the
optional extra and the early release
observations show what a smart decision
that was because it's opened up this
whole set of new phenomena that you just
don't see with the other instruments
yeah
so jumping off from that john this is
this image that i
um
i'm sure it's uh everyone has seen it i
think we have it which kind of does a
comparison and as you mentioned various
other
projects and telescopes that you've
worked on can we see that image image
number 20 that just gives a sense of
the uh the resolution change not not
this one image number two yeah thank you
that one right there
so so
yeah tell us what we're seeing here
yeah so this is a comparison of three
telescopes we've had in space
the
wise telescope is a small one uh sort of
a mirror is about big as your hand a
little bit bigger
the spitzer telescope
is uh
quite a bit bigger and much more
sensitive and it showed us that even
though it was small you could see
pretty far
galaxies
pretty darn close to the big bang not
all the way and then you see in the
right-hand picture the area of the same
thing is so much sharper and so much
clearer and
it reveals features that are now obvious
that weren't so obvious before which are
dust clouds in space
not only are there stars but there are
these wispy things out there which are
really important to our story of where
do stars come from because stars get old
and they blow up and stuff comes out and
it gets recycled into clouds like that
which will then get pulled together by
gravity to form the next generation of
stars with planets so this is uh why
this is such an important story to look
into and and to begin to begin to tell
yeah i mean one telescope is not listed
there but i think it's probably the most
familiar to those in the audience is the
hubble space telescope maybe just to
give a sense
like what's the size of the mirror of
hubble compared to the size of the
mirror of the james webb okay well
hubble mirror is 2.4 meters across about
eight feet and the web is uh six and a
half meters across almost 21 feet so
it's about seven times the collecting
area but you can see what a spectacular
difference that makes
yes
also the hubble can't see it these long
wavelengths that are in this picture you
can't see at all because it's warm right
it glows
like a light bulb
yeah the spitzer telescope the middle
one in that picture was three feet
and that was the most sensitive
telescope that we've had at these wave
wax
and so you go from three to 21 feet and
you actually go as the square of that
ratio that's how you get the 50 times
sharper image and this picture makes it
show that that
you're just seeing things you never saw
before and that's what this telescope is
going to do for us
yeah speaking of things we haven't
really seen before at this kind of
resolution let's look at another image
that was released the southern ring
nebula if we can sort of bring that up
and let me continue with you george
because i think miri played a pretty
critical role
in in
getting this together so why don't you
tell us about this and then marcia maybe
you can give us some near cam insights
into what we're seeing
so this is actually the neurcam image
maybe marshall should describe this
first yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one you probably
that marshall first time you can go
absolutely
okay so
in the center you see a bright star but
it turns out that's not actually the one
that died here
you'll see that in the miri image
what you see around the outer edge is
kind of a chocolate colored very
structured filamentary material and
what this is evocative of is how this
the central star died in a series of
convulsions
and released
kinds of dust that you can you can see
in this orangish
chocolaty like color
and
there are
kind of like little tunnels holes in
this
structure that let some light get
further out
and another thing that i find
very amusing about this picture which
has nothing to do with the planetary
nebula
but along
the left hand side there's something
that looks almost like a little scratch
and
that's actually a galaxy and what we're
discovering with web is that
web is so sensitive in
the sort of three microns and longer
regime that we're very good at picking
up all kinds of galaxies so all of our
pictures are getting photobombed by
galaxies so that's like a edge-on galaxy
i gather right that like little edge
line there yeah amazing yeah that's
amazing and can we bring in the um the
the miri version of this maybe a side by
side i think
was released and we can sort of see
those and maybe georgia can tell us what
it is that we're seeing differently when
we look in the different wavelengths on
the right hand versus left-hand image
so the mirror image highlights these
widths and shells and scallops and so on
and those are
heated up aromatic molecules those are
kind of in between what we normally
think of molecules and dust
and actually they're quite common in
automobile exhaust
and they're called aromatic because they
don't smell very good but anyway
there and they get released when a star
like the sun or a little more massive
than the sun
gets too old for the hydrogen to sustain
it it it's it's easiest to give the star
personality it desperately tries to keep
itself alive by burning helium by
burning carbon
and there's a stage where all this stuff
results in big flows of gas inside the
star
it becomes unstable it starts to
oscillate
and each time it oscillates it throws
off a little more material
and so what you see are these shells are
the past episodes of material getting
thrown off the star
and so by looking at this you can
actually do archaeology on the history
of the star which you can now see is
this uh white dwarf the it's
still to the left of you as you look at
this image the slightly fainter star in
the center
and the reason you can actually see it
with mary is it still buried in some of
the dust it threw off so it's heated up
to
be
brighter for mary
relatively speaking than it is for
narcan that's just another illustration
of why these this wavelength is so neat
but just look at this picture and think
that each one of those filaments each
one of those shells
represents a spasm of this tiny star
until it finally collapsed
down to the white dwarf that's the the
star
that's at the center and is heating up
the rest of the action here
and this is a similar fate that
presumably our son is facing not
imminently but in some five billion
years or so right is this the uh similar
death rows that we envision
yeah
it's first going to blow up to about the
size orbit
yeah and and then it will go through
these spasms and then the core will
separate from the rest of the star
and the coral will become a white dwarf
like the ones in the center of this
nebula and the rest of the stuff will be
in a planetary nebula just like this one
so rene pierre have you guys done any uh
spectrographic studies as yet of uh
this particular source
not as we swear no this one
no no doubt it'll be coming up so let's
also turn then to um
another really beautiful
image uh stefan's quintet
if we can bring up i think that for us
is uh image 24.
uh so this i gather
uh correct me if i'm wrong but this is
now a composite image from
near cam
marsha and and from mir is that correct
this is putting both data sets together
to create this image
it is and the
the near cam part is kind of the fuzzy
whitish colored stuff and the really
interesting part with all the structure
is mostly from miri
it but there is one very interesting
thing the left-hand most galaxy if you
zoom in on it it's actually closer to us
than
the other four which are
actually at the same distance and
interacting with each other but this
foreground one
if you look
zoom in the near cam image you can
actually see some of the individual
stars in that galaxy which
is again just amazing and a testament to
how well the optics are working on on
web
how far away are are they how far away
is the close one and and the four that
are further away
ah
40 million i think the closest one is 40
million
uh light years and the the group the
actual group is close to 300 i think
it's 290 something like that right so so
there's a huge difference so it's just
coincidence that they uh project on to
the sky in the same location there's no
there's no relation between the the left
one and the others
is it unusual though to have even a
grouping of four that are
so is that part of what you're going to
try to be figuring out as these images
are further analyzed
actually um galaxies tend to come in
groups or clusters so it's not that
unusual
um i think the average size of a group
maybe even 10 galaxies so it's not it's
not that remarkable but what is
remarkable here is that these galaxies
are close enough together that they are
starting to merge together which is a
process we think might be very important
in the early universe
and so getting to see these in a
somewhat closer example may teach us a
lot about the physics of how
these galaxy blobs come together to make
a bigger galaxy
yeah if we go back to the image if we
can bring it back up maybe you can just
point it out i gather it's in in the
more or less in the center
of the
group of four there's two that are quite
close together and gather those are the
two that are on the uh verge or
post-merger yes
yes they're the ones that are getting
the closest to merging and and you can
also see that there's
kind of um pinkish glow along
part of the kind of wispy arms and
that's showing where some star formation
is being induced by
the gas compression from the galaxies
coming together
and if we remove say the near cam
contribution i gather that then
exposes the the miri contribution more
directly can we see that i think that is
that image 25 uh
on our list yeah so so george is is this
the the miri data uh without the near
cam uh contribution
yeah i mean looking at this i think you
just have to say wow
this this is this is it right and this
this explains better than a million
words could why the optional extra was
such a good thing to buy
because
look how different this is and in fact
if you had stripped these out of the
previous image
it would have mostly just seen stars and
it would have just like
i'm sorry marcia it would have looked
just like all the previous images
rather than something that was well it
would be sharper you see the individual
stars
but to the untrained eye it wouldn't
look that unique whereas you you look at
this and you say what is that
and that's because all these aromatic
molecules again
are being heated up by young stars and
this trace is where all the young stars
are forming
and in fact there's this one object over
to the right that hardly looks like a
galaxy
yes
it's so busy with forming stars the
object to the left is another galaxy
that looked like a kind of normal galaxy
and now you see that it actually is just
full of these regions of young stars
heating up these aromatic molecules and
glowing force
so so john
were you sold early on on on on
yeah i had no doubt it was the necessary
supposedly optional add-on because it
was so different uh if you just uh
extended the hubble from
what it could do out to five microns
which the near infrared does for us now
that's a factor of three in wavelength
and it may be or maybe it'd not show you
very different things but we knew
from the very first moments that we knew
that this was a possible instrument that
it would show you come something
completely different
that objects are just too cool to shine
in their own visible light
would just be different
so one thing that's really remarkable
about this picture is it's got a quasar
in it it's
an act it's got a black hole in the top
and george can tell you more about it
how way we see it
as we do in the mid infrared um but it's
different so as yes everybody knows we
have a black hole in the middle of every
galaxy and some of them are active which
means things are falling in
and it's getting compressed and hot and
anyways sending out jets so george what
do we see here in this top one that's
different from what we knew before
yeah i want to start by saying a whole
lot of people saw how neat this optional
lecture would be a lot of engineers on
the project help too
so what we see at the top
is
it may be triggered by this interaction
you it's a little hard to figure out how
this gets started but
gas has been has fallen into the
influence of the black hole of course a
black hole by definition is black so it
doesn't glow
so to make it glow you've got to have
gas fall into it it orbits it as it does
so it gets heated to very high
temperatures it even emits very
profusely in the x-ray
and so we are actually this is the way
we can find massive black holes this
black hole is
something like
10 100 million times the mass of the sun
so it's a very massive spot spotted
space
that's heated up and in fact they're
spectra that were part of the early
release that show
some of them just don't know where in
the image this is the upper portion the
the bright upper region
it's it's the thing with diffraction
spikes got it
it's it's nicely isolated by yeah it's
beautiful
yeah
and so suspects have been taken you say
spectra have been taken of this uh
is there any information you give us on
what you learned from taking spectra
actually i think there is one image
where you see the spectra and they are
actually from miri and near spec in this
case and with quite spectacular spectra
from miri this one i think george can
comment on it it's quite spectacular
yeah i'd love to hear it george
so
this again uh covers the wavelength
range of mirrory the
you can see there's molecular hydrogen
that's heated up a really interesting
set of lines are the oxygen line and the
neon line you see the extreme right
those are
those have to have very very hard
deep ultraviolet photons to excite those
atoms and so those tell you that there
is what we call an active nucleus in
there that can't be excited particularly
the neon line cannot be excited by stars
and in fact
these lines are going to be used a lot
with the webb telescope to find active
black holes that are buried so buried in
dust that you can't find them in the in
the visible or even the near infrared
i see that's amazing and what's the uh
what's the mass of the black hole you
said but i didn't hear it
100
yeah
yeah
maybe about 100 million
about 100 million um
so um
yeah go ahead and please go ahead no no
and i think there is basically a next
the next image corresponds to the
neospec version basically this one has
been observed also within your spec
yeah do we have the near spec image of
that
yeah and here it's not presented in the
same way and i think it's quite
interesting because we already talked
when we talked with rene we presented
two ways of doing spectroscopy with
generosity and actually miri and nia
spec
include another way of doing it i call
it the spectroscopic toolbox okay
scientists can just pick the best way to
observe objects and in this one what you
do is you actually get spectra but not
along the slit or not with everything
open but you can get a small image and
you get this clean spectra on the
basically to get a detailed view
spectroscopic view of your objects and
in this case what you can do is you can
reconstruct images at plenty of colors
plenty of wavelengths and this is the
example and what you see is that
depending
at which line you know these lines of uh
you're looking at
some of them are going to to correspond
to ionized hydrogen some of them to iron
some of them to atomic hydrogen then
molecular hydrogen and actually
they correspond to different parts of
the galaxy and in this case actually to
different parts of
regions where this black hole and the
gas the the impact of the black hole
through ejection or even radiation
impacts the gas of the galaxy and you
see this different morphology and from
there you can understand really what
happens in the core of this active
galaxy
a sense of the technological feat of
like near spec how many
shutters how many slits do you have and
and
and how many and how many do you control
can you turn them on and off in order to
fine-tune what it is that you're
actually taking the spectrum of
yes for the spec it's the over mode it's
the one we used uh for the you know for
the first image where we we have a
technology actually developed at the
goddard space flight center which are
tiny micro shutters so the the thing
because remember what ronnie said the
expect needs to select the object to
pick the right one and just mask
everything else
and in this case what we have is four
arrays
in total it's a quarter of a million
almost of uh some micro shutters they
are not larger than the width of air so
it's really really micro shutters
and you can command them individually so
basically you just look at all the image
from nirkham okay martial and nirkham
they always set the stage for their spec
you you take the image you know where
the object is going to fall and you say
oh i'm going to open this one this one
this one and that's what the observer
the scientist will do and from there we
get the spectra so that's the
very novel uh technology actually and
quite impressive
yeah
i think impressive is an understatement
it's a standing feat
uh if we can turn now we have two other
images that i i want to get to before we
conclude our discussion here i know that
john has to uh leave at 4 30 so i'm
mindful of the time i want to turn to
the image that was released having to do
with an exoplanet
and one of the
questions that humanity has asked since
the time we look skyward is whether we
are alone whether there might be other
life out there in the cosmos and the
first step in that direction of course
is to begin analyze in detail
possible atmospheres around the
exoplanets that have now
been in our realm of discovery since the
early 2000s so
this particular
image is a is a quite beautiful and
maybe um maybe renee i think
nearest played a key role in this can
you give us a sense of what we're
looking at and what it means
yeah so here we're looking at a uh the
spectrum of the atmosphere of a uh a gas
giant in fact this is a planet uh about
the the mass of saturn but uh bigger
than jupiter because the planet orbits
its star in only three days and it's
really really heated up and it's it has
a very warm atmosphere and the uh and so
this is a transiting exoplanet so this
is a very special class of planets where
from our perspective the planet goes in
front of the star wants every orbit and
in fact you know
when uh george were having prone to sell
miri to their project back in the early
2000s the very first transiting
exoplanet was discovered in 2001. at
that time we were not planning to study
exoplanet atmosphere but that's a that's
a science team that's imposed itself and
because of the power of probing
atmosphere so the game here is actually
quite simple but also very challenging
so we we have to measure the the uh the
dip of this of the light as the planet
goes in front of of the star and you do
that
with spectroscopy with every colors so
uh if the atmosphere has some you know
molecules like water for example well at
that wavelength that color the planet
will appear slightly bigger and it's
what you see here and if we see bumps
and wiggle that our telltale signature
of molecule in the atmosphere and all
these bumps here are water but in the
nearest wavelength range from 0.6 to 2.8
microns
we can also we're sensitive to carbon
monoxide and also methane
and that's only one
view of the worldwide range but all four
science instruments near cam near spec
miri can also take their part of the
spectrum so this is a very important
science mode with jwsd uh
that will allow us to study exoplanet
and of course uh we're not just
interested looking at uh gas giant
planets we're interested to look at much
smaller planet uh rocky planets that are
in the uh
in the uh temperate regimes uh and we
have targets like this you probably have
heard of this famous planetary system
the typist one system that has uh seven
planets orbiting a very small star not
much bigger than jupiter and uh they all
transit their their their star and three
of them are right in the habitable zone
so the big question is is there any
atmosphere around this planet and if so
what what are they made of and so that
star that plenary system all these
planets will be observed quite a lot in
the first year with all science
instrument to try to answer that
question are there any atmosphere and if
so what what it's made of that's a very
that's a phrase
very first step to assess the the
ability the the habitability of these of
these planets so this is proof of
principle that you can do these kind of
incredibly subtle measurements what
other biomarkers would you be looking
for what would be the moment when you
say wow
this is starting to look like
it may
support the conditions necessary for
life
well it is very speculative but i mean
over the whole weed length range i mean
we can detect we can we are sensitive to
oxygens in the nearest woodland range
but we know that it would that would
require a lot of observation
to detect that in the mirror with length
range there's ozone you know three
oxygens together uh that we could
potentially detect that
but we know that this this would take a
lot of upcoming time to detect this but
it's uh you know we don't really know
and again the very first question we
want to answer perhaps this first year i
hope is uh is there any atmosphere
around around these the these planets
amazing and you know the about 24 25
percent of all upsetting time in the web
in first year will be dedicated to
exoplanet a large fraction of which to
do exoplanet atmospheres but there's
other modes that we haven't discussed
yet and yet are very powerful nearest uh
near cam and miri have specific modes to
do uh high contrast imaging and the
ability to detect
very faint companion exoplanet very
close to their star and that's a major
science team also that's going to take
quite a lot of time in in cycle one in
first year i see
spectacular in the remaining time i'd
like to turn to uh the final image one
that
folks who are fans of space imagery
will know a version of from hubble i
believe the uh
the uh carina nebula can we bring so
this is the hubble image and i you know
if we had time i'd pull the audience to
see how many people are familiar with i
suspect it's non-trivial but it's nice
to bring this up first because now if we
transition
to the new image you really wow right i
mean
again it's just sort of a a startling
moment when you see
that kind of resolution i don't know who
wants to start us off uh uh maybe marcia
do you wanna tell us what we're seeing
here
um we're seeing again a multi-colored
image and off the top of the image where
it it looks almost like a blue sky
there are some um
very young hot stars that are
emitting so much ultraviolet radiation
that there's their
photons are starting to eat into the
edge of this surrounding cloud that was
basically the birthplace of all these
stars
and so this is sometimes called the
cliff
but what's very interesting is that when
you start zooming in you will see some
areas that
um
are not stars because they don't have
the diffraction spikes they don't look
like little snowflakes but are sort of
this yellowish color and some of those
are regions where
a
a baby star not yet really a
full-fledged star we call them
protostars
have jets coming out that are crashing
into the surrounding gas and exciting
shock waves that light up in molecular
hydrogen
and near cam has a has a filter that is
tuned to exactly the wavelength that
that molecular hydrogen emits
and so
we can find these jets and when we start
looking around in here we see all kinds
of
funny little structures it's going to
take everyone quite a long time just
from this one image
to parse out all the things that can
happen in a star-forming region
and that's a pure cam data set
yeah this one is
and there is a version of this i gather
which also has
miri data composited too is that is that
is that this one here is this just
george can you tell us what we're seeing
here
yeah um
this brings those aromatic molecules to
the fore
and so you could see how i mean it's
almost like there's uh clouds creeping
in over the cliffs from the ocean isn't
it
that's not exactly what we're seeing but
that's what it's reminiscent of and and
so you're seeing a whole different
dimension of what's going on in this
this complex of interstellar material
and forming
stars and i guess i should add
part of the secret of what you're seeing
the the last infrared telescope we
talked about a little bit the spitzer
telescope had one moving part among all
of the instruments and what this
discussion is benefiting from is we have
very very sophisticated instruments on
jwst in addition to all those other
attributes
so this is not just a big telescope not
just a cold telescope but it's a very
sophisticated observatory and you're
seeing all kinds of aspects of these
sources that it reveals because of that
yeah you know it's absolutely
amazing so john before we wrap up
obviously this is
kind of day one right this is the the
starting line the shotgun has gone off
and
now scientists are going to be
analyzing this data with great passion
great interest how how is the observing
time allotted i i saw a pie chart i
don't even know if we have it that sort
of gave a sense
um oh yeah there it is so uh
was there some committee i presume that
got together and tried to figure out
which project should get which time
going forward how do you make these kind
of decisions yeah yeah we do it with
committees so
we announced the opportunity for the
entire world to propose
we told them the rules and when
everything was due and
what objects had already been claimed
and so please send your proposal and by
the way write it so we can't tell who
you are when we're reading the proposal
this should be called anonymous
so uh if you're a dog on the internet
and you can spell you can send in your
proposal
so what happened actually is uh it was
much more equitable in uh judging than
before and even got about i think 10 of
the of the winners were graduate
students
so we're welcoming great many new
investigators because they had good
ideas
so now i know
yeah
yeah i noticed it obviously by percent
which is percent of the total viewing
time i gather you got an incredible
dividend from
the launch being so spectacularly
precise that you used a very little fuel
to get
the telescope into the correct position
so i remember we spoke about this in a
program i guess i don't know november or
something and you were hoping for for 10
years
there but you said maybe more now now
what's your view where do things stand
right away we thought well we think we
got 20 years
and then it turns out we're not spending
fuel very quickly so maybe even more
so really i'm keeping our fingers
crossed that we are driving our
telescope
conservatively and cautiously and fuel
economy is good for us
wow so if that's the case conceivably
there are there are graduate students of
the future
yet to be born is that yeah right who
may actually be using this machine wow
that's an amazing thing
well you know it must be uh it must be
incredibly thrilling
to
do
just
people that you're seeing on the screen
besides me all have observing time that
that they are going to keep on going uh
the observations will be taking every
day
and so
we have a full program every five days
we'll have twice as much data as we had
yesterday so
and uh documentation will be published
today and uh the images will be
available for scientists to analyze
tomorrow
and so um we are so thrilled to see this
happening and welcome all of the people
to look at those pictures and say look
what i found you didn't even tell me
that was there
and so uh we are thrilled and so we've
done our job as instrument builders and
telescope builders and now it's over to
the science world
to do what scientists do and take
pictures and figure out what they mean
so before we go on that inspiration i'm
just wondering would anybody want to
pause
a guest
or maybe in your wildest dream
what what insight do you hope
in your wildest dream that the web will
provide does anyone have a a a a pet
question or a pet goal that may be
achieved in the in the not too distant
future
i mean i really hope that
we can
finally settle the arguments about
what kind of object was the first kind
of galaxy like thing to form after the
big bang there's been lots of theories
this way in that way and i hope we can
settle that one for sure
sorry yeah i myself i'm looking forward
about these atmospheres and what we're
gonna we're gonna learn and uh i suspect
there will be some surprises there
amazing and pierre uh i joined uh
martial actually because near spec has
been designed really to look for these
these objects and finding the
spectroscopic signature of a
different composition of this first
object is something that is a kind of
holy grail for
for a lot of uh high rate shift galaxy
aficionados so
yeah same as martial
george
any thought on that
i want to well i want to find where the
first of these supermassive black holes
came from we've found quasars at such a
high riches so close to the beginning
that we're having a lot of trouble
explaining how to grow a black hole fast
enough to power these quasars so that's
a big mystery
so so john give me a final word and just
by preface it by saying you know you use
the kobe satellite
to give us insight into the microwave
background radiation giving us insight
into the big bang itself
what would you dream of happening with
oh my goodness i would hope that we uh
well sort of as an observer i would hope
to find something that we know we're
never guessed was even supposed to be
there
so but aside from that where should we
hope to find surprises
we know so little about the actual
formation of stars so little about the
actual formation of galaxies and black
holes
we have lots and lots of theories we're
getting better computer simulations but
um when i ask uh the computer scientists
well when you're going to show us what
we're going to see before we see it and
they say we can't it is too hard so
my expectation is we're going to get
surprises every few days
that things are not as we thought
amazing well you know i look forward to
hearing about those surprises and again
thank you
well number one congratulations to you
and the entire team thank you so much
for taking the time out to give us some
insight into this first release of
images and
i think i speak for the whole world of
saying it's so exciting to imagine what
might be coming down the pike as the
james webb telescope continues its
mission so thank you all
so much for joining us and to the rest
of the audience let me just quickly note
thank you for being part of this
conversation you should follow the world
science festival there's a little button
where you can click in to follow us
through our newsletter we have
programming both of this sort but on all
manner of science topics under the sun
that will be released in the coming
weeks and coming months but yes today is
a
a real critical moment
the the first step in a new view of the
cosmos that imagine the james webb
telescope will provide us so the whole
world thanks to team
and thank you and the audience for
joining us signing off from new york i'm
brian green
thank you brian
thank you
[Music]
you